in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
americans is far greater
than what divides us just 1.3 of farmers
in this country are black did you know
that
over the last century america's black
farmers have lost more than
90 percent of their land because of
systemic discrimination
and a cycle of debt cbs this morning's
saturday co-host michelle miller
recently visited a farm in upstate new
york that's at the crossroads of racial
equity
and climate change so this is a family
business
farm sisters ashanti and kedesha
williams come from a long line of
american farmers
who've stewarded land in the u.s for
more than a hundred years
but have never owned it our relationship
to the land started way before our
chattel slavery
not just slaves but like sharecroppers
and the way that we have had
access to land facebook has always been
exploitive yeah
we want to change that we want people to
reconnect to own it
to own it
now they're creating a community of
farmers called the black yard farm
so we're just in the backyard
the williams sisters recently moved from
the bronx
to this 95-acre farm in sloanesville new
york
where ashanti is in charge of livestock
and errands include picking up three day
old turkeys
at the local post office kadisha will
run the vegetable operation
all in a sustainable way that helps
mitigate the effects of climate change
it comes down to lessening the carbon
footprint in terms of where our food
comes from and where it goes to
even the baby turkeys will do their part
we're going to graze them we'll put them
out on pasture
so they'll be fertilizing the soil a
non-profit committed to food sovereignty
helped arrange
use of the land for two years at which
point the farmers hoped to own it
so the idea is that throughout the 95
acres as we expand and grow as a family
as a farmer as you said
we'll bring new farmers the idea is
they'll apprentice with us
get rid of programs and then they'll
incubate yeah so incubation is
i've gone through an apprenticeship i've
learned how to do my own business here's
10 acres
here's some startup funds sounds like
one stop shop for how to
create a black farmer that's the idea
at the end of the day if you own your
own land then you have the capacity to
create wealth
and to preserve wealth one of our first
charges agriculture
secretary tom vilsack wants to close the
gap between
white farmers and socially disadvantaged
farmers
the eight years of the obama
administration were focused on trying to
respond specifically to specific acts of
discrimination
so we had a variety of settlements of
class action cases against
the department of agriculture and in
that process one of the things we
learned was that the farm service agency
offices in the past
made it more difficult for some socially
disadvantaged producers to access credit
or when they access credit it was late
in the growing season or it was at a
higher interest rate
so it's a systemic issue president
biden's coronavirus relief program aims
to fix these inequities
by providing an estimated five billion
dollars in aid and debt relief
to farmers of color this is your second
stint as agricultural secretary
there are those who say you didn't do
enough under the obama administration to
help black farmers
who've been systematically marginalized
or discriminated against
well i don't think you ever do enough
but i think i'm proud of the work we did
do
we also expanded the number of black
farmers that received loans
we inserted minority members in those
county committees so people got a fair
shake on appeals it's a steady march
armed with the opportunity of a lifetime
the williams sisters are working to
regenerate their land
along with the lives of those committed
to preserving it
we'll connect with the land in a way
that helps us see that
we belong here and we can treat the
planet in a way that makes it so we can
stay here
for cbs this morning michelle miller
sloansville new york very cool what the
william sisters are doing and after
seeing those little baby turkeys i might
have a whole different view of
thanksgiving i have to say
oh what does that mean no they're
they're very cute yeah well handsome
what's what do they call the tofu turkey
a tofurkey right
here listen it's a whole different world
but i love the commitment that the
williams is
absolutely passion and the talent that
they're doing that's hard work very nice
hard work